[Musica]
[Applauso]
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono a parigi e oggi
siamo su di aus 2
premetto che ho giocato al primo
soltanto che il 2 me lo state
consigliando da secoli e aspettava il
momento giusto per farlo
oggi in teoria doveva uscire il terzo
episodio di the grudge però purtroppo
non sono riuscito a registrarlo perché
in questo momento è tardi e dato che ci
mette un casinò a ritornare al punto di
prima in the grudge penso che lo farò
questo weekend assieme a happy with oros
motori dreams se riesco magari metto due
puntate insieme per recuperare il tempo
perso quindi mi scuso per quelli che
aspettavano the grudge ma lo farò
appunto nel weekend se riesco quindi
dato che può giocare un qualcosa di
abbastanza veloce per oggi vado su di
aut 2 avevo giocato al primo un'idea o
se mi aveva terrificato abbastanza però
al 2 non c'è ancora giocattolo a dire
che possiamo iniziare the legends
vabbè faccio che tradurre se riesco per
quanto la mia produzione faccia pena
vabbè per stringere la cosa c'è scritto
che essa casa abbandonata abitava una
famiglia e tutti quanti si sono
suicidati fine praticamente una bella
favola prima di andare a dormire
cos'è che ti insight andiamo bene non me
lo aspettavo
è permesso ho portato le pizze che avete
ordinato you are now inside di house non
vedevo l'ora
ok ci siamo first del living room come
si presenta all'inizio è veramente
fantastica molto pulita sembra camera
mia appunto quando non la rispolvero
comunque c'è una bella foto perché bella
famiglia ma che bella bambina guarda non
lo so perché ma ti sarebbero bene un
paio d'occhiali comunque
posso sentire qualcosa di strano in
questa casa attualmente mi sembra il
primo giorno ha paura di tradurre di
merda e non traduco bene c'è anche una
luce qui che posso premere che figo
devo andare avanti come primo di haus a
premere tutte le cose ripetutamente
finché non succede qualcosa penso di sì
ok
buongiorno ho portato delle pizze no no
non è lei vero che devo consegnare le
pizze che schifo verso il successo
raga avete dimenticato lo shop aperto
spero spero sia shampoo alla ciliegia
fragola al pomodoro
non so che cos'è ma non mi piace andiamo
avanti mortacci di tua sorella porca
[ __ ]
porca lasciam perdere e cambiate la nota
che cazzo
vabbè a volte rideva adunate la notte a
volte chiamava bambino mi fa piacere
spero che qualcuno non fosse fa vj
perché nel caso di non le rispondevo che
cosa devo fare adesso devo premere
ripetutamente la foto finché non appare
qualcosa ma non c'è qualcosa da un
terrier software
ok mi fa piacere dato che adesso mi hai
aperto un mondo questa cosa
sono contento che grazie mille adesso
veramente vado a dormire tranquillo e mi
fa piacere però non deve succedere mosso
con capitan a ok è bene di farci slot ci
snob stronza ok the bathroom debba fare
un bellissimo
ok siamo passati al cesso raga che bello
allora abbiamo qui è un bello scarico da
tirati salsicce veramente lo scarico
l'ha tirata
c'è la tenda della doccia mi fa piacere
so già che qui dentro non succederà
nulla di buono ma non fa niente
la bibbia molto carina come cosa grazie
al pensiero e anche lavandino che bello
non so se qualcuno ha avuto le
mestruazioni qui ma al cesso era un po
più a sinistra però non fa niente
vabbè lasciamo perdere noi apriamo tutto
a caso come al solito sesso
salve
ho delle pizze ancora io non ho niente
sono andato perché ok
oddio che schifo ma che merda no vabbè
da ma che schifo è avvenuto a casa
qualcosa lancioni sunreef or what i've
done
[Musica]
[Applauso]
tu orchid place for games guarda io ti
perdono volentieri basta che mi dice
dove a chi devo consegnare le pizze poi
me ne vado
6 perdonato ok ci sono delle gambe ci
sono le gambe all'interno della doccia
ci sono delle gambe
apriamo la doccia già che ci sei lavati
piedi
senta
non lo so che non è il momento adatto
però io qua devo consegnare occupato
sono accesso né o per un po ok
devo fare buongiorno ho detto che ne
abbiamo per un po mamma mia che non c'è
neanche più la privacy nei cessi ragano
cosa assurda ford gm ho capito ti volevo
perdonare io ti volevo perdonare ti
volevo per tornare chi vuole io volevo
perdonarlo the bedroom raga di bene in
meglio e fantastico
esistono gli assorbenti quando vai a
dormire lasciamo perdere
ok gli oggetti da cliccare sono staff
aree non ci posso credere
ve la ricordate raga non idea di che
cosa sia
non mi piace quest'anno si ok basta
basta no no no no no questo no non ho
seriamente basta
e stato notato il 24 dicembre o che
bello la vigilia mi fa piacere
e adesso che sosta cosa che cosa
dovrebbe succedere adesso che sosta cosa
a parte che ombre passano davanti a me
senza alcun motivo
posso soltanto cliccare se cose il suo
livello fatemi capire c'è qualcosa qui
ci conservi night
spero non stanotte perché mi chiudo a
chiave
però va bene anzi di avermi avvertito
prima ok raga ma c'è un altro biglietto
ci sveli godin hiding a i never found è
veramente brava nasconda sì non la trovo
mai per sicurezza va bene un altro
biglietto she loves playing hayden sic
mi piano la mi fa piacere che ti piace
giocare a nascondino però i non sono
dell'umore adatto per farlo adesso non
sono dell'umore adatto per farlo perché
devo consegnare delle pizze
lei ei miei non posso sono in servizio
allora ciao a tutti i capi di nascita e
va bene ancora sto coltivando la via
ragazzo continua d'africa le stesse cose
perché tanto non non posso fare altro
c'è qualcosa qui ma che bel disegno e
tipo la pagina dello slider adesso me la
foto è siamo uno sotto da karima pescina
[Musica]
buongiorno sigrun cazzi ok la vista che
porca [ __ ] però ma che palle sta cazzo
di bambina ok hai finito see the working
rom ragazzi stiamo arrivando alle 6 from
state tranquilli che prima o poi ci
arrivo ok
accendi la luce si è accesa non ci
speravo
c'è qualcosa qui
ok perfetto c'è una boccetta di qualcosa
c'è un cavo c'è
e poi c'è una lettera si
ok la data di nascita ok un altro
certificato a caso non mi chiedete che
cos'è ok poi c'è sempre questo poi c'è
sempre il cavo poi c'è sempre questo fa
di nuovo la luce
poi c'è di nuovo questo c'e di nuovo il
cavo
poi c'è di nuovo le foglie c'è di nuovo
la luce poi c'è di nuovo questo poi c'è
di nuovo il cavo poi c'è stat roja il
capitano ma [ __ ]
senta non so se era lei prima pesa nella
doccia
però avevo chiesto gentilmente di farsi
un bagno per ora ben fa niente senta
devo devo spegnere perché c'è cos'è o
dio sa qualcosa in tasca di luminoso non
sono un metal detector ma vedo qualcosa
sei fermo trovato la chiave per la 6
from raga ce l'ho fatta
andiamoci però non posso cliccar la
evidentemente ok devo accendere la luce
è mi scusi non vorrei importunarla in
questo momento di relax però avrei
bisogno di sapere come arrivare alla 6
from
non è molto socievole vero ok io
continuo a cliccare roba a random spetta
sperando che succeda qualcosa prima o
poi ok è sparita è sparita calmi
giochiamo al impiccato prima lettera era
sono veramente o che c'è qualcosa qui
bike and sand stifler rest in peace mai
ma perché ma mi spiega datemi un motivo
datemi la motivazione ok ragazzi sono
cosa devo fare qui può mettere un codice
raga non so cos'è provo un secondo con i
miei scritti raga sono 7988 ok e le
fratte europa ma si può uscire
esatto e questa è la cosa giusta
nel frattempo vi ringrazio anche perché
siete veramente tantissimi comunque 7988
proviamo 7.900 perché mai dovrebbe
funzionare una cosa del genere non lo so
sono pazzo perfetto non ha funzionato
magari si è iscritto qualcuno nel
frattempo va bene che non so cosa devo
fare
abbiate pazienza non so cosa devo fare
ciò è fatta già fatto non ci credo non
ci credo
due ore per trovare la soluzione però se
ho fatta perfetto c'è un foglio e sono
sicuro che questo mi dirà a chi
consegnare finalmente la mia pizza why
why have to die ma mai volto league non
metal guai perché devo morire ma ma io
voglio vivere non importa mi porta cosa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e normale che è uscita una bambina dalla
cassaforte è normale
cosa devo fare qui
fa tutto
mi son cagato addosso e che [ __ ]
la pizza me ne vado ok ho detto ho detto
che me ne vado ho detto ho detto che me
ne vado
ho detto che me ne vado 7
ok raga è stata la cosa più orribile a
cui abbia mai giocato lasciamo stare
vi ringrazio per avevano consigliato in
tanti alla fine la pizza non l'ho
consegnata però spero che se la si è
mangiata lei evidentemente perché forse
aveva fame affari risale in chiusa lì
dentro
comunque va beh mi scuso nuovamente se
non è se oggi non è potuto uscire dal
gregge ma non ho avuto tempo di
registrarlo e vi ricordo che come
prossima puntata nonostante sia piena di
spaventi sarà anche più lunga del solito
per recuperare il tempo perso
comunque come al solito se video di oggi
vi è piaciuto lasciate un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
al solito trovate nella descrizione di
ogni mio video se non siete a quelli
siti iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazzi ok perfetto
bella ragazzi